with Star Wars the last Jedi coming out
next week I realized I've never done a
Star Wars countdown and that got me
thinking about my initial exposure to
the series being ten years old when
episode 1 came out I grew up with both
the original and prequel trilogy 'he's
like millions of others i was introduced
to the original films early and loved
them by Star Wars experience kicked into
high gear in 1997 with a special edition
theatrical re-releases and it was a
dream come true for 8-year old me to see
my heroes up on the big screen
soon after I found out a new trilogy was
being created centering on the backstory
of Darth Vader and how the young Jedi
known as Anakin Skywalker turned to the
dark side to become one of the most
iconic villains in cinematic history I
was definitely excited but I wasn't a
fan then nor am I now of prequels very
rarely do they work or need to be told
in the first place I wanted to see the
story move forward what happened to Luke
Han Leia Chewie and all my other
favorite characters after Return of the
Jedi at that point it had been about 15
years since Jedi's release and I had
imagined what could have been going on
with these guys since then I heard there
were comics books and video games
expanding on that time period but I
didn't know enough about them at the
time and just wanted to see Star Wars as
I originally did that being in movie
form so while I was excited for more of
those films I was going into my first
viewing of Episode one The Phantom
Menace knowing I wouldn't be seeing most
of the characters I already knew thus by
the time May of 1999 came around my
expectations weren't quite as high as
other kids I knew I still liked it when
I first saw it as most people did but by
the time Attack of the Clones was
released in May of 2002 I had realized
something I didn't like it almost at all
it was around then that I began noticing
I wasn't the only one massive
disappointment from the older fans began
to become more and more well-known and
accepted when episode 3 came out I
remember having mixed feelings I'd there
were some things I liked
but many I did as time has gone on I
find
myself liking the films less as films
themselves and more for the memories and
nostalgia surrounding them I can
appreciate the good parts which there
are some but overall I was heavily
dissatisfied with the way the main story
across all three movies played out so
while I acknowledge that I grew up with
these films almost as much as I did with
the original trilogy and do have
somewhat of an attachment to and even
some small fondness for their misguided
contributions to the Star Wars legacy
there are a lot of things that really
suck at these movies let's talk about
them these are the top five worst Star
Wars prequel moments number five there
were a lot of candidates for this spot
but in the end I had to put a Jar Jar a
moment in the countdown from Episode one
The Phantom Menace Jar Jar is on
Tatooine with qui-gon jinn and tries to
eat some raw meat hanging in the street
market when he finds out it costs money
he spits it out at the nearby Sebulba
after he gets in trouble for this young
Anakin shows up to save him and the rest
is history
so pretty much Jar Jar is to blame for
everything there are many annoying
moments from Jar Jar in episode one but
for me this took the cake his pandering
slapstick hit the breaking point for me
here and he's just a jerk throughout the
movie plus he's creepy look at that face
if you've never heard about the Darth
Jar Jar Theory look it up it's the most
interesting thing about a character that
almost everybody unanimously hates
alright that's enough to are moving on
number four
you are in my very soul tormenting me
this scene has been in my very soul
tormenting me from episode to Attack of
the Clones Anakin and Padme got the hots
for each other but can't be together
because he's a Jedi and I'm a senator so
they fight their urges by sitting alone
in the dark next to a romantic fire
there are plenty of awkward moments
between Anakin and Padme I was close to
choosing the infamous sand line but
we've gotten so much joy out of it
through memes and the like that it's
become a moment of joy for me so it gets
a pass I don't like sand also this
exchange from Episode three might be
just as bad you're so beautiful
it's only because I'm so enough
no no it's because I'm so in love with
you so love is blinded you but I chose
the your in my very soul scene because
of how absurdly melodramatic it is the
whole love story in episode 2 is a huge
reason why I consider it the worst of
the three prequels the dialogue between
these two is awful and their chemistry
was never believable if you're suffering
as much as I am please tell me I am
number three at least this moment ranks
as one of cinema's signature knows from
episode 3 revenge of the sith lord Vader
has just awoken in his new robotic body
when the emperor tells him that Padme is
dead he doesn't take it well when I
first saw this in theaters everyone in
the crowd cracked up in that moment they
made Vader a joke the road that led here
was already bashed but this was the
moment where the Darth Vader we all
recognized cried like a baby I'm not
saying he shouldn't have been upset or
just not reacted to hearing his wife
died but I can't think of a worse way to
do it this was terrible you can argue
that like the Sandline this has become a
funny enough meme that it should be
forgiven from being on a worst list but
I could not give this one a pass all
right we're done see you later we have
two spots left number two I've been
wondering what aren't midi-chlorians hi
I like on June oh this is my girl is
everything
midi-chlorians man from episode 1 The
Phantom Menace and it can ask qui-gon
what midi-chlorians are his response is
that they are microscopic beings that
live in the cells of all living things
they are what connect everyone to the
force this fundamentally changed a lot
of what we knew about the force by
trying to break it down to biological
reasoning instead of the mysterious and
mystical source that it was previously
established as I do want to mention that
Liam Neeson's delivery here wasn't
really bad actually whenever qui-gon was
trying to mentor young Anakin it gave
the film a little bit of a heartbeat
that it could have used way more of in
any case the way they tried to dismantle
and explain the force goes against
everything that made it so cool in the
first place it takes the mystery away
and replaces it was something nobody
needed to know maybe instead of may the
force be with you we should say may the
midi-chlorians that you may or may not
have a high concentration of alert you
to the presence of the force and its
will I should make that a t-shirt and
the number one worst Star Wars prequel
moment is henceforth you shall be known
as Darth Vader
[Music]
think this is what everything was
building up to why how did Anakin turn
to the dark side it was the basis for
the whole prequel trilogy from episode 3
Revenge of the Sith
Palpatine admits to anakin that he is
the sip floor the Jedi have been looking
for Anakin tells mace windu of this news
which triggers a confrontation between
mace and Palpatine having promised to
teach Anakin how to save his wife from
dying
Anakin stops Windu before striking a
final blow on Palpatine which leads to
maces death
Anakin then breaks down and pledges
himself to your teachings I still get
angry watching the scene this was
supposed to be the culmination of
everything a question we wondered about
since hearing obi-wan discussed Vader in
the first film and later when we find
out that Vader is Luke's father how and
why did Anakin turn to the dark side how
this played out was so weak and
disappointed I will do whatever you ask
I understand they set up Anakin's
prophetic death dreams in Episode two
but to just give up so easily to an evil
he just exposed was ridiculous all this
was to save Padme but it's not given a
hint of believability how a good guy May
a supposed galactic hero turns evil
needed to be done with care and
precision this was a flimsy excuse at
best that somehow still felt rushed even
though it had three films to build it
off there are so many easy avenues they
could have gone down that would have
made for a better turn but instead
Anakin goes from hero to killing kids in
like five minutes it also didn't help
that we never saw much of Anakin being a
hero in the first place all the
interesting stuff with his heroic side
happened off screen what we saw in
episodes 2 & 3 was a whiny child who it
was very difficult to have any sympathy
for that is what made these films so
frustrating they promised us the
downfall of a hero what we got was the
stumble of a little wood over on my
personal channel I've been reviewing
season 4 of Star Wars rebels and we'll
have a review up of the last Jedi as
soon as possible so check it out for
more Star Wars content I want to hear
what you guys think what is your least
favorite Star Wars prequel moment what
do you want me to cover next on the show
leave a comment and let me know to keep
in touch like my face
page facebook.com slash awesome Walter B
or follow along on Twitter to take part
in more polls about what may be covered
in the future come back next week when
we delve into more positive territory
with this series you'll be very cool
[Music]
you